[Applause]
okay
good
morning good morning presidents
ministers distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen thank you for joining us
today for the first Business Roundtable
between the European Union and Latin
America and the Caribbean I am kundun's
director General at the European
commission and I will be moderating
disciplinary session
all of you here are absolutely key in
taking forward the global gateway
investment agenda
throughout today we will be discussing
and we will have ample time to discuss
the key strands of the investment agenda
and explore opportunities for investment
in various sectors but before we start
just a few practical indications the
opening session the keynote addresses
and the closing session are open to the
Press
and can be followed online
the seven round tables are closed
sessions meaning that only the
participants and those in the listening
rooms will be able to follow them these
sessions are under Chatham House Rules
so no attribution of specific comments
can be made
interpretation for everything is
possible and available in English in
French in Spanish and in Portuguese and
now I would like to welcome the
president of the European commission
this is Ursula Wonderland
[Applause]
good morning to all of you president
Lula prime minister Sanchez president
goldfein president yes granados it's
such a great pleasure to welcome all of
you here in Brussels
today's Summit marks A New Beginning for
an old friendship
but it's also a new beginning that
builds on Decades of a good friendship
our two continents are brought together
by shared culture
a shared belief in the U.N Charter
but also by the vital role that business
plays
think of digital startups from Latin
America that are expending here in
Europe in fields spanning from AI to
farming
European Investments are creating good
jobs in Latin America Latin American
companies produce
radioisotopes and they are used for
cancer treatments in European hospitals
we have Investments of the European
Union in Latin America in sectors
ranging from Finance to Automotive from
chemicals to clean energy
businesses are the lifeblood of our
partnership
and they build the bridges that link our
two continents
these connections have driven up for
years trade and investment flows
between our continents
but also technology transfer and
Technical cooperation
and a new people-to-people agenda
but there's so much untapped potential
we can do so much more and this is why
I'm so pleased that the two days of our
Summit begin with this Business
Roundtable
Latin America
the Caribbean and Europe
need each other more than ever before
the world we live in is more competitive
more conflictual than ever before
still reeling from the heavy toll of the
covet pandemic
the world is taking a hard impact from
the Russian aggression against Ukraine
and this happens
against the backdrop
of China's growing assertiveness abroad
so what does it mean for our two
continents
and especially what does it mean for our
businesses
it means
that we need to make our economies more
resilient
to external shops
and that we have to fight inequalities
and poverty in our societies
it means that we need Partners we can
trust
we want to engage with investors and
trade with countries who share common
principles and common values
and to prove reliable
in the short term but also in the long
term
Europe
aspires to be the partner of choice
to Latin America and the Caribbean
just like we choose to be a partner to
the region
we believe that Europe's offer to the
region
is different
and significant
we have the mutual interest in seeing
Latin America the Caribbean and Europe
unleash the full potential
we share the common interest in seeing
both our Industries grow
local value chains develop
and more and more people rise into the
middle class
we do not just want to trade together
but we want to thrive together
and for all these reasons
we have decided to step up our
cooperation
so today I am glad to launch our
investment agenda for Latin America and
the Caribbean
we call it global gateway
under the banner of global gateway we
propose to bring over 45 billion euros
of high quality European investment to
Latin America and the Caribbean
[Applause]
over
135 projects are already in the pipeline
from clean hydrogen to critical raw
materials
from expanding the high performance data
cable network
to even producing the most advanced mRNA
vaccines
but only together
can we agree on sectors and value chains
to prioritize
and how we can best boost these
Investments with skills with standards
and with technical support
so let us use this Summit
to shape the investment agenda
and to benefit on both sides of the
Atlantic on our continents
ladies and gentlemen
global gateway has not only the size to
make a difference
but it lays out a new approach
of how to want we want to invest in big
infrastructure projects
European investments will come with a
strong Focus
on creating local value chains we think
it's so important that the added value
stays locally so together
we can build Supply chains that are
resilient
and important is that this added value
stays in Latin America and the Caribbean
this is also in our interest and let me
give you two examples that show why we
have a common interest and shared ideas
the first example is clean hydrogen
Latin America and the Caribbean have a
potential to become a global Powerhouse
for renewable energy
you have all the resources in abundance
abundance
your wind and solar sectors are growing
exponentially
also thanks to European investment the
natural next step now is
to turn clean energy
into clean hydrogen
on the one hand
clean hydrogen can easily be exported to
other continents
and on the other hand and crucially
clean hydrogen can also fuel new
Industries on your continent
just imagine clean steel and concrete
clean fertilizer
clean trains and buses all of them made
in Latin America and the Caribbean
so your continent has the potential to
be a global leader in the clean industry
of tomorrow
second example
is critical raw materials
if we want to be successful in the green
and the digital Technologies
our Industries need access to critical
raw materials
Europe wants to be your partner of
choice
unlike other foreign investors we are
not only interested in investing in the
pure extraction of the raw materials
we want to partner with you to build
local capacity
for processing
for making batteries and for the final
products like electric vehicles
and besides investment we can contribute
world-class technology
and high quality training for local
workers
and this is precisely the kind of
investment
for which we created global gateway
ladies and gentlemen
Europe wants to launch a new partnership
with the region
and this is why today's Summit is so
important
for the first time in eight years
the leaders of our two continents are
coming together
we're coming together to discuss among
other things a shared investment agenda
fall Latin America and the Caribbean
we now need to hear from you during this
Business Roundtable
about the sectors you want to focus on
and the bottlenecks we need to address
together not everything is easy there
will be hiccups and the bumpy road but
the investment is there the political
will is there and people expect us to
deliver
so we want that we can invest right
where you need it the most
and as I said at the beginning it is a
new beginning of old friends for which
we not need to join forces I wish you
all a very good Business Roundtable
thank you for coming to Brussels it's
good to have you here many thanks
thank you
[Applause]
thank you president for your welcoming
address and now I have the great honor
to welcome the president of the
federative Republic of Brazil his
Excellency Louisiana Lula da Silva and
invite him for his welcoming remarks to
the Business Roundtable
[Applause]
gracious
very well
it's with great joy
that I'm here
being to be able to be here in this room
greeting
the president of the European Commission
mademoisa found their lion
the president of the government of Spain
Pedro Sanchez and our president of the
inter-american Development Bank Ilan got
fine
and our brother executive president calf
Development Bank of Latin American
Executive president Sergio Grenada my
dear Ambassador foreign affairs minister
of the government of Brazil our dear sir
Modine
and my dear Ambassador Pedro Miguel
Britain Ambassador Brazil in Spain
business men and women
all attendees dear friends
I have great pleasure
in to participate in the opening of this
business meeting
side by side of the president of the
European Commission of the prime
minister of Spain and of the presidents
of the idb and CAF I believe there are
the companies the universities
and Civil Society
that give life and continuity to the
relations between countries this meeting
reaffirms that our entrepreneurs are
fully engaged in the relaunching of this
historical Alliance based on the
certainty that the success of one is
fundamental for our common success
pandemics
code with 19 pandemics beside
the Lost of millions of lives it the
it's unorganized a productive system in
all around the planet the climate change
shows clearly the urgency to preserve
biodiversity and ecosystems
the Democracy crisis leads to hatred
disagreements violence intolerance
undermining the living conditions in
society and the planning of economic
activity the war in the heart of Europe
has launched over the world the
uncertainties and channels for
War purposes resources that were
essential for the economy and for social
programs
the arms race makes it even more
difficult to confront the climate change
issue
vis-a-vis all these challenges
its responsibility of the rulers
businessmen and women and workers to
rebuild the roads to prosperity to go
back to industrial production investment
and jobs
the Latin American countries and the
Caribbean countries will continue to
perform a strategic role for Europe and
for the world
because we are a region with
great opportunities for investment and
to enhance consumption
we are countries that demand investments
in infrastructure infrastructure
Diversified Logistics social and urban
infrastructure we are civil societies
that undertake strong social Mobility
for which we have new and very Dynamic
domestic markets integrated by hundreds
of millions of consumers the European
Union is the second largest trade
partner of Brazil
uh trade flow could go beyond this year
the landmark of a hundred billion
dollars the agreement between mercosu
and the European Union which should be
balanced which intend to conclude this
year will open New Horizons we would
like to have an agreement that will
preserve capacity of the different
parties to respond to Future and present
challenges government procurement are a
vital tool to network investments in
infrastructure and sustain our
industrial policy
the U.S and European Union are leading
and already adopt industrial policies
that are very ambitious based in
government procurement and domestic
content
Brazil
has a great domestic Market of 203
million people with great capacity for
consumption that is still
and uh still weak and that will demand
the enhancement of investments in
consumer goods inputs and Associated
Services we will launch in the next days
a new investment plan to confront the
existing bottlenecks after the last six
years where we had a backwardness
situation in stagnation we will go back
to create jobs of good quality fight
poverty and to increase the income of
the Brazilian families the plan for
seized going back to Investments that
were paralyzed accelerating the ones
that are underway and selecting new
projects for Investments we will promote
the modernization of our logistic
infrastructure with investments in
highways railroads Hydro waves a
Waterway projects and pro ports and
airports Brazil has already energy
Matrix of one of the most cleanest ones
in the world 87 percent of our
electricity power already comes from
renewable sources
against 27 percent of the world average
and 50 percent of all our energy
and 50 of all our energy is clean while
in the rest of the world the average is
only 15 and we will improve even better
these figures because we are giving
priority to the generation of solar
energy wind power solar power biomass
ethanol and biodiesel and it's also
tremendous our potential for high green
hydrogen production we can also
highlight new opportunities in urban
Mobility basic sanitation disaster
protection low housing financing
generating stimuli in the productive
chain of transportation and construction
the extension of on to the national
territory of a network of high band with
great capacity will serve as a basis for
educational policies that we're trying
to develop and prioritize in Social
inclusion and quality an education of
quality is a requirement for a growth
that is based on technology generation
and Innovation giving privilege to the
knowledge economy we will establish
Partnerships between government and the
private sector and in all these fields
on the public concessions and ppp's
private and Public Partnerships and
direct contracts
this new Brazil there will be more fair
with much more fairness and solidarity
will be rebuilt without giving up our
commitments with the macroeconomic basis
the control of inflation and the balance
of public spending are essential
requirements to assure stability a solid
base for economic expansion and social
progress
with the fiscal reform underway in tax
reform underway we're simplifying tax
collection and making our economy more
efficient we have a robust Financial
system that will allow sustainable
expansion of credit during the next
years
our high International Hot currency
reserves today around
343 billion dollars makes us a safe
buffer vis-a-vis external volatilities
when we launched this ambitious program
of investment I'm not thinking only in
exclusively in my country we don't want
to be an island of prosperity we will
only grow in a sustainable way through
the integration to our regional
surroundings in the last South American
leaders a summit meet in May in Brazil
the capital of Brazil I have proposed to
update the project portfolio of the
planning and infrastructure South
American Council reinforce a
multi-modality and prioritizing projects
of high impact of physical and digital
integration especially in the Border
regions when we built the bio ocean
Corridor that links Central and West
Brazil to the port in the north of Chile
reducing the cost of our exports to the
Asian markets and creating job and
income for the interior of the Latin
American or South American continent
when we hosted The Summit meeting of the
Amazon countries that will be happen
next August we try to network common
initiatives for the protection and
sustainable development of this biome
with other seven countries of South
America the Amazon region we have
a unique natural asset in our hands in
terms of uh
drinking water biodiversity and Forest
this condition makes us very responsible
in the management of this wealth for
sustainable exploitation and
preservation in an inclusive way which
is something that is a national
imperative
in the previous terms we reduced
deforestation 80 percent this time we
have taken the commitment to eliminate
deforestation in the Amazon zero differs
until
2030. and then already in this semester
we managed to reduce deforestation in 34
vis-a-vis compared to last year we're
now launching the basis to
re-industrialize the country with
undertakings that will be less pollutant
with greater technology density and
creation of jobs green jobs and quality
jobs Brazil has come back to the
international scenario to contribute
in the to confront the challenges that
our planet faces such as climate changes
and the increase of inequalities we are
going to prove as we already did in the
past that it is possible to produce and
to grow in a sustainable way and in an
efficient way ladies and gentlemen we
need to send to the world a sign a
signal that the two regions of grading
strategic importance as Europe and Latin
American the Caribbean region are
committed with a very promising agenda a
peace agenda of cooperation of enhancing
trade
and Investments that will create new
jobs and sustainable growth
when we have a lot of money in the hands
of very few then we have income
concentration and very few people
consuming while many face difficulties
with a better income distribution and
money in the hands of many not few we
can make available resources on the base
of society increasing consumption and
generating opportunity in services in
the manufacturing and agricultural
Industries this is true in each one of
our countries and even more true when we
think of this in global scale Brazil is
doing its part with a strategic with the
strategy and the law for the long term
focus on credibility predictability and
judicial stability
social and social inclusion and economic
stability
only this way there will be managed to
develop in a definite way our countries
these are the essential factors for us
to build
a future that is full of opportunities
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you Mr President and I
would like to welcome now and invite on
the podium our next speaker his
Excellency Pedro Sanchez
the president of the government of Spain
which is holding the rotating presidency
of the Council of the European Union
thank you
first of all
Ursula I'd like to thank you for
organizing this business forum witchware
is taking place in Brussels in the
capital of Europe and also to thank you
for this commitment you've shown which
is so firm
for the success of this European EU
select uh Roundtable and Summit
with your the 45 billion euros so thank
you very much Ursula you have always
been so
um sound in um external uh Affairs
um and based on all our uh principles
thank you uh president Lula for being
here today in the inauguration I believe
that in Brazil
the leadership of Brazil in this area is
essentially in order for the to achieve
success in today's Summit today and
tomorrow and are very aware of this
extraordinary efforts you're making
to be here today in Brussels
and also congratulations to the presence
of the CAF and the idb for the excellent
work they've done we started talking
about this business forum and this
Summit in May of last year and today
we're beginning to see the results of
this extraordinary effort which we've
all been making so dear representatives
of European and Latin American companies
and international financial institutions
the you the Spanish presidency the EU
has taken on a very objective a very
ambitious objective which is to
strengthen external relations between
the EU and Latin America and the
Caribbean these are regions which
as Lula and the presence of the
commission were saying we have solid uh
historical links with common values and
interests we have a shared vision of how
to deal with the uh Global challenges of
humanity and therefore we want to
relaunch our
um trade and investment links we want to
strengthen the resilience of our
economies
and with this objective we are
celebrating this Summit
and I would like to mention some of the
most important aspects of these first of
all trade
because the European Union and selac
have
balanced trade links which is different
from what we have with other parts of
the world EU lag have uh balanced links
which have grown enormously enormously
in the last few years and now it
currently
300 million uh 3 300
000 million euros per year
um and I think that our economies are
complementary
um Latin American Caribbean possess
energy and abundant raw materials uh uh
Sun fertile soil water and uh 40 of
biodiversity 33 of water uh fresh water
in Latin America is present in Latin
America and therefore uh president
Lawless marvelous to hear you talk about
the Amazon as you do
it's also marvelous to know that your
government is going to protect this
public good
such a global of global importance what
can Europe bring to the table well not
only Capital technology know-how to
Latin America in the Caribbean which
they need in order to
launch their Economic Development even
more intensely in order to take
advantage of the complementarity of our
two regions I think it's important that
both regions deepen our trade relations
and our economic integration today I can
say that the ratification of the
agreements with Chile and Mexico is very
close and this is a great deal to do
with the leadership of the European
commission and therefore we really
believe that this will happen during
this Spanish presidency of six months
and as regards the relationship between
EU and mercosur after more than 20 years
of negotiations we believe that we now
have a window of opportunity dear called
president to ratify it in this second
half of 2023 and of course Spain will
always be side by side with those who uh
want to close on this very important
agreement which is very important for
both regions
Spanish government and the European
commission are working intensively
to achieve an agreement on those
environmental climate aspective aspects
are still outstanding so important
bearing in mind this sovereignty also of
the countries of mercosur but we're also
thinking of what this might involve
because we're talking about 94 of GDP of
Latin America and Caribbean would be
under the in the framework of free trade
agreements with the EU generating more
jobs and more wealth
shared wealth by uh shared by both sides
as regards trade secondly
and somebody like to say that
a few comments on the global gateway
investment agenda we know that Europe is
has
has increased its investment by 20 on
last year but Latin America in the
Caribbean have also become an important
investor into Europe and here
there's a a community a business
Community which represents these
interests represents the Latin American
and a Caribbean business community
000 million dollars per year in the last
decade
via the multi-latinas
and Spain is obviously the first
destination in Europe of this investment
where we want to have we want to expand
the investment of Latin American
Caribbean in the rest of Europe we
believe that strengthening our economic
relations Demands a greater effort uh
greater investment from the European
Union
and we agree this this with um the
president of the European commission
this is very important for the private
sector and here the global gateway of
the EU is going to play a very important
role and uh president referred to this
this is a agenda of strategic projects
concrete projects we're not talking
about abstract matters these are
contract matter the concrete matters and
we'll look at some of these in a moment
accompanied by technical assistance
know-how uh skills and something very
important which is
um harmonization of the regulatory
framework and Spain is committed to this
agenda therefore we have taken a step
forward with the mobilization of 240
million a billion euros in the coming
months and um the Spain and the other
members of the EU will contribute will
play their part and I very much welcome
that we've achieved such a high figure
has just been announced by the
commission
over and above this effort a key role
played by the multilateral Banks the
development Banks which are here present
for the financing of these projects and
thirdly
the last I will conclude with this we
have to mobilize the private sector the
European businesses which are present
here today thank you very much for
coming
are global leaders in many sectors and
they can bring to the region the capital
the technology the know-how the skills
necessary for diversification of exports
with the creation of jobs in the uh
value chain on both sides of the
Atlantic and this with the greatest
commitment and respect as the president
Lawler said of social standards labor
standards and environmental requirements
I will conclude by saying that EU and
select are now in a situation which I
would describe as uh hopeful and it can
be improved
it can meet our necessities and
interests in areas of critical raw
materials digitalization renewable
energies the re-industrialization and
social and economic cohesion of our
territories and therefore I would
encourage the companies here present to
join this agenda to support it it's
going to strengthen our economies it's
going to improve the welfare of our
citizens and it's going to create
greater interdependence between two
continents two regions of the world
which we which share values interests
and also a multilateral vision of how to
resolve the global challenges which we
are now facing I think that we can all
win from a closer relationship and
that's what we're trying today after
eight years to try to relaunch this
close uh links and to strengthen the
links between both
continents I don't know any better way
of beginning the week thank you very
much
thank you
thank you Excellency and our next
speaker is Mr goldfein he's the
president of the inter-american
development bank and co-host of today's
Business Roundtable
okay
good morning bongia buenos dias bonjour
I'd like to start by greeting president
Lula as well as the ministers that are
present here I'd like to also
say how important it is that we're all
here sharing this moment that's of great
importance for our region and for our
countries
president Sanchez
Spain has been a constant strong partner
of Brazil and Latin American in the
Caribbean and I'm sure that Spain's
presidency of the European Union will
raise our cooperation to new heights
yesterday we were all having discussions
on strengthening our cooperation
cooperation between our different
institutions and associations hosting
this round table a true honor president
with us your message today and this
course the youth commitment for renewing
partnership with Latin America
I will divide my remarks into three
parts first some context EU lack release
you have not started today with Europe
and with the idb
I'll then discuss our share priorities
for finally I'll review some big
opportunities for Europe and Latin
America and how the idb can help size
these opportunities
the Europe and Latin America Caribbean
have a strong trade and economic
relationship let me tell you why last
year
EU and Latin America trade totaled
369 billion euros
trade is well above pre-pandemic levels
the U.N just announced that foreign
direct investment in Latin America surge
to a record
225 billion dollars last year
and from that European foreign
investment in Latin America is bigger
than India China and Japan combined
and nowhere has European support for
Latin American development be clearer
than I'm glad to say through the idb we
have 22 non-regional member countries 16
from Europe
1313 from the EU
European countries have shape of
strategy that we have donated fund at
co-finance projects mobilized resources
and much more let me give you some
examples
with the French development agency we
jointly Finance 6.3 billion in Social
climate infrastructure digitalization
projects
Spain cooperation fund for water and
sanitation has directly benefit 3
million people in Latin American
the EU Finance with us the Central
American digital trade platform which
reduces trades and promotes integration
in Peru we have now was just announced
the largest wind power plant thanks to a
collaboration between the private sector
arm the idb vest
and France NG and European Banks private
sector in the past year alone European
commission are located 20 35.5 million
in Grants
to projects from Health to trades there
are many other examples
at its time to be more ambitious
today we heard the new agenda to
strengthen EU lactase from president
Wonderland
you have said before that the Strategic
partnership is more important than ever
we cannot agree more
the Strategic partnership can lead us to
more clean energy
faster green transition better Protected
Their biodiversity and have
deforestation stronger more diverse more
productive economic integration
digitalization
and has president Lula says more
equality in several Dimensions we cannot
forget it
if you wonder if these benefits are for
the region of Latin American caribrah I
must tell you no is for both regions
several of our shocks including the
Russia's invasion of Ukraine brought
Global challenges including food and
energy security to the top of the agenda
in both regions
I want to tell you
Latin America and Caribbean could be an
important part of the solution to Global
challenges
this makes
the new opportunities not not only
necessary but attractive to all of you
from the private sector
we have one of the world's largest
democracies in Latin America
and that ties our historical and
cultural ties with Europe
this is a time of align priorities
so let me tell you what are the idb's
priorities social issues including
poverty inequality food security
Education Health
infrastructure physical and digital to
boost productivity and for regional
integration climate mitigation
adaptation including the green
transition and don't forget the
importance of the Amazon
we need more private sector involvement
and I'm glad that you are here
this is all part of a broader vision for
the region we have to reposition Latin
America as part of the solution to its
own challenges but also Global
challenges
two examples that were said before
Latin America and Caribbean's home to
two-thirds of the world's lithium 38 of
copper
crucial for the great physician we
already have on average
30 percent of Latin America's total
energy much larger than any other place
double the world average
with the right investment we can beat
the global source of clean energy
just the second example food security
we already the world's top net food
exporter but with the right incentive
and the right framework we can produce
more than eight times more and feed the
world
today I must say our region stand at a
Crossroads
never before have our region been better
positions to help each other address our
bigger challenges
the idb is and will continue to be the
partner of choice of the European
commission team Europe development
initiatives in Latin America we have
jointly mobilized the European fan for
sustainable development plus guarantee
program
her spider of choice in the past month
we have been working closely with the
youth identify several projects aligned
with the use Global agenda investment
and and we will continue to do so we
apply these initiatives and together
with our partners half we will
strengthen it
we have built of years of experience in
Latin America
since Joseph
created the idb in 59. we are creating
enough with Innovative financial
instruments to mobilize Capital to be
the conduit
of Investments to Latin America and
maximize the impact of every Euro in
Latin America
last month for example in terms of
innovation we help Ecuador to do the
world's largest debt for nature
conversion
we have Pioneer like in Uruguay the
sustainability link bonds
Germany help us launch the green bone
conspiracy platform
which covers 75 percent of the region
issuance
we now need to simplify scale these
instruments we need more concessional
and more blending finances we want to
work with Europe to explore guarantees
reducible risk including for protecting
the Amazon
presidential
we welcome the new leadership of Brazil
in the Irreplaceable part of the world
that is
the Amazon
we applaud Brazil's new leadership
in the Amazon in other places
the idb has just launched
Amazonia forever
that's Minister Marina Da Silva hint
Amazonia by simply amazing
this is an umbrella holistic Regional
program to boost diversity by focusing
on people
and the bioeconomy and infrastructure is
the program to coordinate several
existing initiatives including idb's own
Amazon initiative this on initiative we
already have Germany internal alarms
Belgium Spain Switzerland the UK and All
European members contributing to the
Amazon issues but we want to be brother
we want a regional program Amazonia by
assembi and the private sector has a key
role in our strategic relationship
we have mobilized from the private
sector only last year from the idb
invest 3.1 billion
just idb invest mobilizing that but our
collaboration with the private set goes
far beyond
financing and capital we have knowledge
we have technical assisted we can do all
of that creating job opportunity and
increasing the standard of living of
people in Latin America ribbon
especially women and other
uh communities the private sector
experience and Innovation is key in
advancing digitalization and climate
action
so we want to ensure that not only we
have good investment opportunities but
we are collaborating in a trillion
manner what we need is to increase
development impact so let me conclude
here with my main messages
for the European Business Leaders now is
the time to engage more in Latin America
and the Caribbean
second is a great opportunity Latin
America because the region is uniquely
positioned to be part of the solutions
to its own challenges but to the global
challenge like climate change food
security biodiversity third idb is to
prepare to be your partner both
European and public and private and we
all have the potential to take you Latin
American Career relationship to a new
level and doing so to enhance impact and
help both of our regions solve our
challenges
I want to thank the host the co-host
again and everyone in attendance I wish
all of you productive discussions today
and at assignment thank you
thank you and I wish our conference
every success
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much and last
but not least I would like to invite to
the podium Mr Diaz granados
the executive president of the
Development Bank of Latin America and
also co-host of the Business Roundtable
[Applause]
excellencia
France president of the European
president of the federative Republic of
Brazil Mr Eleanor de Silva is Excellency
prime minister of Spain Pedro Sanchez
president of the idb ambassadors
John says thank you very much for
attending today I would like to start by
thanking
Mr Sanchez Mr lulara Madam Von delayan
for their excellent introductions it's
an honor to be here today and my
colleague Iran golfen and the head of
the team of the idb and calf development
teams who have provided support that was
vital for this meeting to be held
being in Brussels reminds me of what
Sean Monet said a pioneer of Europe he
called on everybody to be ambitious and
he said we have to decide whether people
are ambitious for themselves or for they
what what they want to achieve after
eight years where we've had a lack of
political dialogue and a political
vacuum now Latin America and Europe need
to be more ambitious and need to be more
involved in our Pathway to
sustainability and progress we're living
turbulent times as we've heard and our
citizens are expecting concrete results
from these high-level meetings now is
the time to speed up our activities
what we are doing and we need to
redefine our bi-regional relationship to
a great extent the relationship between
the EU and the Lac countries has in fact
uh been a little bit one-sided up until
now we have done activities in certain
countries in certain ecosystems in
certain areas and that is what has
defined the trade relationship and
development and sustainability that we
have had so far but that has left gaps
the lack countries have a great deal
that they can provide for the present
and future of Europe and similarly
as Mr Sanchez and Madame Van Der Lyon
said Europe has the capacity to actually
help our regions as a whole to benefit
our citizens and to benefit the planet
in this ambition of achieving things I
welcome what
lion has said of a financial allocation
of 45 billions aimed at reducing poverty
and inequality and ensuring that we move
to a fair green transition and also
ensuring we have a digital transition
which can lead to more inclusive
sustainable
transitions we have an immense
opportunity ahead of us to unite and to
make progress against climate change and
investing in innovation in new materials
renewable energy Digital Services
electromobility and a new role for raw
materials with the transfer of
technology and strengthening our
industry and what Madame vandelion said
was quite right and was very timely for
the lack of countries we don't want the
lack of countries to be seen as an area
where all we do is extract raw materials
but rather as a partner in solving
Global challenges partner not just a
supplier of raw materials the same goes
for the digital transition we have to
ensure that we have proper connectivity
we need to work on cyber security so
that we can have digital solutions that
will underpin our Democratic systems and
the use of such technology in education
systems Health Systems and corporate
systems is vital
we have to show that we're ambitious
about what we can achieve as Mr Monet
said and that's what the global gateway
is it's one of the main vectors being
used by our European partners and the
igb 102 National and Regional
initiatives have been prepared to ensure
connectivity to 85 percent of Colombians
in the rural area by 2026 and helping to
produce hydrogen in Chile and Uruguay
ensuring sustainability in San Jose in
Quinto in Montreal video in Sao Paulo
and also ensuring that we have more
renewable energy in Jamaica as we were
discussing with the Prime Minister this
morning we also need to provide clean
water and we also need to reduce
child malnutrition in Ecuador for
example we're thinking about how we can
use Innovative financial instruments
such as guarantees hedging loans blends
all kinds of instruments to ensure
progress for this to happen it's vital
that we have Partners such as the
European Central Bank and their
directors of the international monetary
fund we are needing to be more audacious
in designing financial instruments that
can be used to help countries
and we in June actually had president
Lula president macron amongst others at
a high level Financial meeting last
month and the financing and common
project is intended to accelerate the
development and use of more financial
instruments the lack countries have
proven capacity when it comes to putting
forward ideas and solutions this bank
for example actually was set up in 1968
as and
bank that would Finance development in
Latin American countries and that's what
we need a bank that is of the region for
the region that works with its partners
and more than Spain and Portugal have
been involved in this for more than 20
years to ensure that the lack countries
actually have the financing they need
and this benefits not just them but also
Europe
sustainable development is something
that actually grew out of the Rio plus
20 Summit in the black region and that
led to the Strategic Compass now we see
the global gateway as a tool whereby we
can achieve the sdg goals by 2030
the Spanish presidency of the Council of
the European Union it shares this Vision
this long-term vision and it's actually
doesn't want to see countries set
against each other but working together
that's the kind of ambition we should
have and I would thank Mr Sanchez again
for having called an unprecedented
meeting of all the economics and finance
ministers which will take place in
September in Santiago de Compostela
and I would like to thank the Prime
Minister that has actually called for
meetings of development Banks too to be
involved
this is going to be initiative of the
World Bank the IMF and us so that we can
actually achieve as Jean Monet said
we are going to be working with our
counterparts as well as the select
chairs to ensure our agenda is actually
achieved president vandelion the last
time I was in this building was 11 years
ago with the trade minister of Colombia
where my Peruvian uh
colleague actually signed the Free Trade
Agreement 11
years afterwards this provides this
agreement provides
legal certainty in terms of the rules
for both sides when it comes to trade I
listened to what president ruler said
for us to have America's
agreement we need not just optimism but
we also need to look to the Future and
as Mr Sanchez said that in fact we have
to look at the GDP that we have that is
trade between the two blocks as well as
with the us but Mercury agreement will
lead to more ambitious and deeper trade
relationships and that will mean that as
Mr Lula has said we will actually have a
closer relationship and we also have to
bear in mind the tendering procedure
launched by President Lula in May for
regional integration and
interconnectivity
that is one reason why Latin America is
important because it's an economic
Powerhouse
with millions of inhabitants and
a very large GDP we all hope that in
fact we will be able to live up to the
level of ambition that we've set
ourselves and that we can achieve things
together we're at a turning point for
democracy and our
we are seeing social movements in Europe
and in Latin America that show this and
at times when in fact Europe has faced
difficult times Latin America has been
there for us
and there have been a lot of people who
left Europe all the different countries
100 years ago for Latin America
and
who now their equivalents are fighting
for a safer country going back to Jean
Monet
we may know who we are but we are facing
challenges in our existence which are
likely to grow and we can only face
those if we Face them together Latin
American countries Caribbean countries
and European countries
such a United stand is something that we
can show to the rest of the world we can
show to the private sector the banks to
sub-regional governments that we can in
fact design a better world for all of us
working together is something that
reflects our commitments and we need the
kind of decisions that will lead to a
changing point in history and calf as a
sub-regional bank calf as a part of
selac which promotes the interests of
black countries is more than ready and
willing to work with all of you thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
so we with this we've come to the uh to
the end but I would like to ask the
presidents indeed to go on stage
okay
[Music]